der
minister rief ihm das wort vielen dank
frau präsidentin meine sehr geehrten
damen und herren wir wissen will was
eine regierung vorhat der müssen den
haushalt schauen und wer in den haushalt
einzelplan 14 reinschaut er kann ganz
genau erkennen was wir vorhaben wir
haben nämlich vor diese bundeswehr stark
zu machen so stark dass die
gewährleisten kann die landes- und
bündnisverteidigung
auch zu gewährleisten meine damen und
herren wir haben angesichts des brutalen
angriffs tricks auf unter ihnen doch
alle feststellen müssen dass wir auch
bereit sein müssen war für unsere werte
einzustehen auch mit militärischen
mitteln und dann muss ich auch bereit
sein und in der lage sein dieses zu
gewährleisten und so wie das in den
letzten jahren erfolgt ist mit den
ständigen zusammensparen im einzelplan
14 und damit genau bei der bundeswehr
die das gewährleisten muss die landes-
und bündnisverteidigung
wäre das nicht weiter möglich gewesen
deswegen ist es gut und richtig dass
diesen worten wir wollen die bundeswehr
stark machen wir wollen die landes- und
bündnisverteidigung
gewährleisten auch taten folgen nämlich
im einzelplan 14
und das kann sehr genau sehen
und 14 ist in diesem jahr vorgesehen
50,1 milliarden euro für diesen bereich
und das ist mehr als das was vorgesehen
war im ansatz nämlich 2,8 milliarden
euro mehr als der ursprüngliche ansatz
vorgesehen hat und das zeigt auch es
einem ernst ist mit dem was man vorhat
nämlich die bundeswehr stark machen oder
ob es einem nicht ernst ist und ich kann
ihnen sagen wir nehmen diese aufgabe an
unternehmen daneben haben wir ein
sondervermögen zur verfügung 100
milliarden euro eine unglaublich große
summe aber es ist genau das was wir
brauchen um die lücken zu schließen die
entstanden sind durch jahrelanges
zusammensparen bei der bundeswehr
dadurch dass wir jetzt endlich die
menschen in der bundeswehr so ausrüsten
so ausstatten wie sie es verdienen dass
wir das gerät die waffen an schaffen die
wir brauchen um unsere aufgabe
nachzukommen und dass wir damit die
sicherheit für die bürgerinnen und
bürger unseres landes aber auch im
bündnis gewährleisten können denn da
wird sehr genau darauf geschaut ist
deutschland bereit seine aufgabe
nachzukommen seiner verantwortung
nachzukommen ich kann nur ein klares ja
auf diese frage antworten
ich sag auf diese sondervermögen ist
natürlich auch eine aufgabe und eine
verpflichtung für uns denn es muss jetzt
auch schnell gehen bei der umsetzung
dessen was damit möglich ist und wenige
wochen nachdem wir dieses sondervermögen
beschlossen haben haben wir mittlerweile
bereits 65 vorhaben identifiziert die
wir damit finanzieren und 41 davon sind
sogar schon haushalterisch ganz klar
abgesichert und können jetzt auch zum
vertragsschluss gebracht werden das ist
zügige umsetzung und darauf kommt es in
diesen zeiten an meine damit
wir müssen zeigen dass wir ein
verlässlicher partner sind aber dass du
auch ein gut ausgestatteter partner sind
im bündnis das erwarten unsere
verbündeten von uns meine damen und
herren unterfangen nicht erst an mit ist
mit diesem haushalt mit diesem
sondervermögen ganz ganz konsequent die
bundeswehr anders aufzustellen sollen
wir machen das schon seit der
amtsübernahme im dezember ich will in
einer gewaltspiele nennen denn es hat
ganz schön lange nicht es ist da wenig
entschieden worden weil es mich warum
vielleicht weil man sich nicht getraut
hat gegenüber der industrie wenn man
nicht die partner gefunden hat ich weiß
es nicht warum man so lange gebraucht
hat und die tornado nachfolge zu
entscheiden wir alle wissen doch dass
20.30 schluss ist dass diese tornados
nicht mehr fliegen können und deswegen
ist es gut dass diese entscheidung jetzt
gefallen ist und sie ist nicht nur
gefallen sondern 20 26 werden den ersten
maschinen bei und sein dass es
konsequente umsetzung genau so wie man
stern transport und schwein schweren
transporthubschrauber da wird
reingerufen rolf mützenich ich glaube
nicht dass der rolf mützenich die
nachfolge des schweren
transporthubschraubers verhindert hat
nein es war die zögerlichkeit die da im
wege stand und gut dass das jetzt
aufgehoben ist wir haben die
entscheidung getroffen und 20 26 werden
auch hier die ersten geliefert meine
damen und herren wir haben die
entscheidung über die bewaffnung von
drohungen endlich getroffen und zwar 20
24 kommt es gegen die truppe ja manchmal
kommt es auch darauf an dass man die
guten die richtigen argumente auch
vorträgt um entscheidungen dann auch
durchsetzen
gelungen denn die truppe die truppe kann
sich jetzt aber auch verlassen das sind
durch diese bewaffnung der ton sicher
erfüllen kann dass sie in ihren
einsätzen noch deutlich chef noch
deutlich gesichert wird meine damen und
herren gegeben aber auch völlig
unkonventionelle wege durfte box denken
und dann auch so handeln beispielsweise
bei einem vorhaben wo ich von der presse
gefragt wurde wieso kauft eigentlich
eine verteidigungsminister in eine werft
ich kann ihnen das sehr gut beantworten
weil die erfahrungen die bisher gemacht
wurden waren dass unsere schiffe viel zu
lange bei der daten auch die
instandhaltung in behaften gelegen haben
und es war wichtige zeit verloren
gegangen ist für die ausbildung und auch
für die einsätze wir haben jetzt die
möglichkeit genutzt als diese werft
durch ein insolvenzverfahren zur
verfügung stand dieses zu kaufen und
jetzt dafür zu sorgen dass solche
prozesse deutlich schneller ablaufen
können das ist unkonventionelles handeln
aber das ist eben auch schnelle
umsetzung meine damen und herren gerne
beschaffung vereinbart wir haben das
handgeld für kommandeure erhöht und
damit mehr verantwortung in die truppe
auch gegeben und wer mit soldatinnen und
soldaten spricht der ecke das auch schon
längst machen können weil das ist das
was mir spiegelt wurde bei den ersten
besuchen bei den ersten gesprächen also
muss man dann auch nicht nur zuhören
sondern auch umsetzen und so werden wir
das auch machen mit weiteren maßnahmen
ich habe da noch
das vor
meine damen und herren die
erwartungshaltung ist hoch sie ist groß
und ja da kommt ordentlich was auf uns
zu der kanzler hat angesprochen wir
haben auch eine verpflichtung eine
deutsche initiative zur luftverteidigung
zu starten und wir sind schon in
gesprächen mit unseren europäischen
nachbarn sich daran auch zu beteiligen
weil das ist der richtige weg auch in
dieser frage eine europäische
koordinierung eine europäische
zusammenarbeit zu gewährleisten und
nicht jeder vor sich hin zu rüsten das
ist der richtige ansatz und genauso
werden wird diese fähigkeit lücke die
besteht auch schließen meine damen und
herren dann nämlich noch ein weiteres
großes thema ansprechendes mir während
meiner sommerreise begegnet ist und das
ist das thema infrastruktur
da muss ich erleben dass es gar nicht am
geld hapert das so oft in kasernen die
situation eine nicht mehr akzeptable ist
oder bei hallen man da geht es darum
dass in den ländern die entsprechenden
kapazitäten in den landes bauverwaltung
nicht vorgehalten werden und auch da
gehen wir jetzt neue wege wir bieten
nämlich an mit unserem know how aus der
bundeswehr heraus solche verfahren zu
bearbeiten damit deutlich schneller geht
und wir nicht darauf warten müssen dass
vor ort diese kräfte dann auch
eingesetzt werden kann das ist out of
the box denken und dann aber auch
entsprechend fahre ich könnte noch eine
eine lange liste aufmachen aber mir ist
es wichtig noch einige wenige worte auch
zusagen zur unterstützung der ukraine
wir werden nicht nachlassen bei der
unterstützung der ukraine und wir haben
unglaublich viel abgegeben aus den
beständen der bundeswehr unglaublich
viel abgegeben aus den beständen der
bundeswehr aber ich sag es an dieser
stelle auch ganz klar da sind hier an
die grenzen gestoßen da sind hier an die
grenzen gestoßen und jeder der mal so
locker flockig fordert ich möge doch
bitte 100 davon 200 davon unter 10 von
dem abgeben da kann ich nur sagen ich
werde sehr genau darauf achten dass sich
die landes- und bündnisverteidigung auch
in zukunft gewährleisten kann darauf
habe ich einen eid geschworen die
bürgerinnen und bürger dieses landes
aber auch im bündnis verlassen sich
darauf und auf mich können sie sich bei
solchen entscheidungen verlassen meine
damen und herren aber die gehen andere
wege und pläne zu unterstützen
und da ist wollen angefragt worden ist
denn eigentlich beim ringtausch sei bzw
die behauptung aufgestellt man es sei
gar nichts passiert als er gar nicht nur
raten vielleicht nochmal die sommerpause
nachzuarbeiten und die eine oder andere
zeit um zu lesen denn selbstverständlich
sind wir vorangekommen der rente aus mit
tschechien ist abgeschlossen der
ringtausch mit der slowakei ist
abgeschlossen und wir sind auf der
zielgeraden
beide bei griechenland und das zeigt
dass es manchmal vielleicht ein bisschen
intensivere beratung braucht aber man
dann auch zum entsprechenden ergebnis
kommt und genauso werden wir auch
weitermachen wir werden weiter machen
die ukraine zu unterstützen aber immer
auch darauf zu achten dass wir keine
deutschen alleingänge vornehmen das wird
mit uns nicht zu machen sein da ist es
auch ganz wichtig sich immer mit unseren
verbündeten abzustimmen und diesen weg
werden wir weitergehen meine damen und
herren zeigen sie bitte mit der
zustimmung zu diesem haushalt der
ausdruck dass wir eine starke bundeswehr
wollen weil wir mehr sicherheit auch für
unsere bürgerinnen und bürger wollen
dass sie hinter diesem anliegen stehen
ein herzliches dankeschön
ich habe dann noch einiges vor sagt
bundesverteidigungsministerium christine
lambrecht es dürfte die soldatinnen und
soldaten eine freundin trotz
sonderprogramm für die bundeswehr trotz
sofortprogramm fehlt es doch noch an
vielen an schutzwesten nachtsichtgeräten
und modernen funkgeräten
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen
liebe frau ministerin ich schiebe vorab
vielleicht finden wir mal die zeit um
die letzten acht jahre gemeinsam zu
rekapitulieren denn ich habe da doch
irgendwie ganz andere erinnerungen dran
als die die wir uns jetzt gerade ob ich
sie vorgetragen wurden
ja da machen wir mal eine größere runde
davon es ist nun über sechs monate her
dass der bundeskanzler die zeitenwende
ausrief was haben wir seit dem 27
februar nicht alles an ankündigung
gehört eine übererfüllung der zwei
prozent quote ein zusätzliches im
grundgesetz verankertes sondervermögen
mit 100 milliarden euro zur finanzierung
über jähriger beschaffungsvorhaben
schluss mit trägern schluss mit zaudern
alles mit dem ziel wie es der
bundesfinanzminister ausdrückte die
bundeswehr zur wirksamsten armee europas
zu machen dieses ziel unterstützen wir
als union ausdrücklich und fordern auch
heute wieder dass die bundesregierung
die hierfür notwendigen haushaltsmittel
aufbringt um dieses ziel
schnellstmöglich zu erreichen
[Applaus]
debattieren wir heute beim
haushaltsentwurf für den einzelplan 14
welcher im vergleich zum vorjahr
300 millionen euro weniger umfasst
angesichts dieser großen ankündigung
seitens der regierung ist dieser schritt
nicht nachvollziehbar und in anbetracht
der inflationsentwicklung schlicht
unverantwortlich die fehlende
ernsthaftigkeit bei der umsetzung der
eigens ausgerufenen zeitenwende fällt
nicht nur uns als oppositions- auf
sondern auch unseren partnern in europa
wie auch nicht denn mit blick auf die
sicherheitspolitischen bedrohungslagen
richten sich die geschäften augen
unserer verbündeten
verständlicherweise auf die entwicklung
in der selbsternannten führungs nationen
deutschland
immer wieder verspricht die regierung
ein stärkeres engagement um die
übernahme von mehr verantwortung für die
sicherheit unserer partner aber die
erwartungen unserer verbündeten an uns
insbesondere die der baltischen staaten
werden zeitenwende rhetorik zum trotz
nicht erfüllt
die dissonanz zwischen den ankündigungen
der bundesregierung und ihren handlungen
ist unsäglich und führt dazu dass unsere
verlässlichkeit als verbündeter von
zahlreichen staaten offen und in aller
deutlichkeit in frage gestellt wird
vergeigt da winkt aus ein kaum zur
rationalisierung der haltung bei
waffenlieferungen an die ukraine und der
fehlenden dynamik bei entscheidungen
über die zukunft der bundeswehr struktur
sowie einer weiteren notwendigen
beschaffung sei dank und dennoch
erwartet der bundeskanzler dass unsere
europäischen nachbarn sich an von
deutschland geführten projekten
beteiligen wie zum beispiel der
europäischen luftfahrt werden es ist
doch so dass die durch die nato
beabsichtigten planung alles übertreffen
was von unserer bundeswehr in den
letzten 20 jahren geleitet geleistet
werden musste wir schalten um von
wechselstrom auf gleichstrom zu einer
dauerhaften belastung unserer
streitkräfte ohne phasenwechsel um
dieser dauer behalten belastung
standzuhalten bedarf es einer massiven
kraftanstrengung nicht nur von unseren
soldatinnen und soldaten sondern von
dieser regierung und unsere damen und
herren in uniform hierzu zu befähigen
erstens sehe ich ersteres sehe ich
tagtäglich auf letzteres wartet man
vergeblich
der ukraine kriegt zeigt einmal mehr die
bedeutung von landstreitkräften dies
spiegelt sich auch in den nato
verteidigungsplanung wieder hier hat
deutschland mehr als nur eine division 1
gemeldet das war richtig dass maßnahmen
ergriffen werden um die
einsatzbereitschaft der zehnten
panzerdivision bis 2025 herzustellen
aber diese stellt lediglich einen teil
schritt in erfüllung unserer nato zu
sagen da für eben diese erfüllung dieses
schrittes beabsichtigt die
bundesregierung die ebenso wichtige
zweite mechanisierte division materiell
zu kanalisieren und personell verweisen
zu lassen so wird in diesen verbänden
die erhaltung des ausbildungs und
übungsstunden nicht möglich sein dieses
kurzsichtigkeit popsongs begründet darin
dass sich die bundesregierung weigert
die zeitgleiche modernisierung der folge
division finanziell zu ermöglichen
aber trotz des krieges in der ukraine
dürfen wir keinesfalls die anderen
konfliktherde auf dieser welt
vernachlässigen
insbesondere zum deutschen engagement im
rahmen des - mandates bleibt die
bundesregierung dem parlament viele
antworten schuldig seit monaten reagiert
die bundesregierung erotisch auf die
entwicklung in der region und dann sich
scheinbar nicht auf eine gemeinsame
position einigen hier muss die
bundesregierung dringend stellung
beziehen
unabhängig dessen gibt es in afrika auch
andere geostrategisch enorm wichtige
regionen in denen sich deutschland
zumindest in form von
verbindungsoffizieren verstärkt zeigen
sollte hierzu gehört zwingend das horn
von afrika
generell gilt es festzuhalten dass sich
in den vergangenen sechs monaten zu
wenig bewegt und zu wenig materialisiert
hat trotz zeitenwende geehrte frau
ministerin ihre rede zum haushaltsgesetz
2022 beendeten sie mit den worten ich
zitiere ich bin zur beschleunigung
bereit ich bin bereit zu handeln dies
freut mich außerordentlich dass sie
hierzu bereit wären aber dann müssen sie
das auch tun wenn die regierung die und
das tempo in der umsetzung der
zeitenwende welche sich in den letzten
sechs monaten erlebt habe und tagtäglich
sofort bevor geführt wurde dann werden
diese ziele eben nicht erreicht werden
können der vorliegende entwurf für den
einzelplan 14 überzeugt uns als cdu csu
fraktion nicht
sagt lasst den vier enkel hat hier auch
nochmal auf die un-friedensmission
- mal hingewiesen fast vier wochen pause
gab es da durch die bundeswehr heute
wurde bekannt gegeben dass ich jetzt
wieder aufklärungs einsätze anbieten
gibt
und sebastian schäfer ist schon für
bündnis 90 die grünen am podium
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin frau
ministerin sehr geehrte kolleginnen und
kollegen in der vergangenen woche konnte
ich an einer delegationsreise zu den
einsätzen der bundeswehr und in mali und
niger teil in das starke engagement
unserer soldatinnen und soldaten vor ort
ist bewundernswert so schwierig die
bedingungen dort sind unsere soldatinnen
und soldaten unternehmen alles was im
rahmen der mandate möglich ist um die
zivilbevölkerung zu schützen das land zu
stabilisieren und so die
entwicklungschancen vor ort zu
verbessern sie brennen für ihren job
es war sehr positiv festzustellen
dass die truppe sich gut ausgestattet
fühlt das ist absolut zentral die
rettungskette funktionieren und mit
einem neuen krankenhaus auf dem
stützpunkt in grau ist auch die
medizinische versorgung idealen
natürlich stellen sie sie stellen sich
im zusammenhang mit dem einsatz viele
fragen aber das wird von den beratungen
zum 1 plant 14 zu weit weg von
friedrich merz hat die bundesregierung
heute vormittag dafür kritisiert dass
die nato quote im entwurf für den
bundeshaushalt 2012 und 20 nur 1,6
prozent beträgt
nun ich empfehle ihm und dienen liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen von der union
einen blick ins gesetz das sie ja
dankenswerterweise mitbeschlossen haben
mit hilfe des sondervermögens werden im
mehrjährigen durchschnitt von maximal
fünf jahren zwei prozent des
bruttoinlandsprodukts auf basis der
aktuellen regierungsprognose für
verteidigungsausgaben nato kriterien
bereitgestellt im mehrjährigen
durchschnitt
und es macht sinn jetzt die verstärkten
beschaffungen einzusteigen und nicht
alles geld sofort zu verausgaben die
strukturreformen beim weinen sind
angelaufen die beschaffung wird neu
aufgestellt so dass wir die mittel so
gezielt und so effizient wie möglich vor
ausgaben können und keine teuren show
feuer entzündet werden das ist ja ihre
spezialität
schwere transporthubschrauber schiffe
gepanzerte fahrzeuge die können sie
nicht über nacht bauen
allerdings will ich auch festhalten nur
weil wir ein sondervermögen zur
ausrüstung der bundeswehr haben müssen
nicht alle beschaffungen und
investitionen darüber laufen auch im
kernhaushalt sollten wir weiterhin
relevant investitionen einplanen
andernfalls droht der einzelplan 14
angesichts von lohnsteigerungen und
kostensteigerungen bei material halt
langfristig abgeschnürt zu werden das
müssen wir jetzt schon mitdenken
an mindestens einer stelle sich großen
handlungsbedarf der ertüchtigung des
titel im einzelplan 60 wird vom
auswärtigen amt und dem
verteidigungsministerium gemeinsam
bewirtschaftet daraus finanzieren wir in
diesem jahr die unterstützung für die
ukraine daraus haben wir aber auch eine
unteroffiziersschule in nidda finanziert
die wir in der vergangenen woche
eröffnen konnten unsere nigrischen
partner sind für die unterstützung
außerordentlich dankbar der titel für
die ertüchtigung initiative wurde im
ansatz jetzt von zwei milliarden euro
auf 700 millionen euro abgesenkt obwohl
das geld in diesem jahr voraussichtlich
vollständig abfließt da müssen wir noch
einmal ran
wir wissen nicht wann die schreckliche
russische aggression in der ukraine
endet wir müssen weiterhin alles dafür
tun dass die ukraine ihre freiheit und
selbstbestimmung verteidigen kann
[Applaus]
zeitenwende dass deutschland seine
geschichte und verantwortung gerecht
wird im verhältnis zu den beiträgen die
die länder in mittel osteuropa und dem
baltikum leisten ist unser beitrag zu
klein um der ukraine noch besser zu
helfen können wir in dieser notsituation
lücken in der ausstattung der bundeswehr
zu lassen die wir dann mit den mitteln
aus dem sondervermögen schnell wieder
schließen können das haben drei
expertinnen aus der ampel sie ja sehr
schlüssig dargelegt
[Applaus]
wie putin versucht unser land unseren
kontinent mit fake news und dem
aussetzen von gaslieferungen zu
destabilisieren dem müssen wir uns und
das sind alle demokratischen kräfte in
unserem land gefordert mit allergrößter
entschlossenheit entgegen stellen
herzlichen dank
sebastian schäfer durchaus auch
selbstkritisch hier zum grenze plan 14
verteidigungminister redner ist rebecca
lucassen er sitzt für die fdp fraktion
im verteidigungsausschuss des bundestags
[Applaus]
frau präsidentin meine damen und herren
die regierung legt die grössten
verteidigungshaushalt
in der geschichte der bundesrepublik
deutschland vor gut 50 milliarden euro
neun mal so viel wie der ukrainische
verteidigungshaushalt vor ausbruch des
krieges und wie jedes jahr müssen wir
uns fragen was bekommt deutschland für
dieses geld wie abwehrbereit ist unseren
bundeswehr wie kriegst tauglich ist
unsere bundeswehr zum grössten
verteidigungshaushalt
seit gründung der bundesrepublik kommt
doch die größte zusatz geldspritze der
geschichte republik zu 100 milliarden
euro sondervermögen für die streitkräfte
ja frau ministerin das geld wird
gebraucht
gleichzeitig zeigt diese enorme summe
wie sehr die bundesregierung der letzten
zwei jahrzehnte unsere streitkräfte
kaputt gespart haben jetzt könnte man
sagen schwamm drüber die hantel
koalition packt es an und tatsächlich
hätte man am 27 februar dieses jahres
den eindruck gewinnen können dass die
bundesregierung versteht was jetzt zu
tun ist bundeskanzler stolz verkündete
eine zeitenwende zeitenwende
die bundeswehr doch für eine gute
verteidigungspolitik braucht man nicht
nur geld sondern vor allem fähiges
personal
das die politischen rahmenbedingungen
setzt um dieses geld auch um investieren
zu können und bei allem respekt ein
solches personal sehe ich in der
regierungsbank nicht
frau ministerin lampe recht herr
bundeskanzler der verteidigungshaushalt
den sie hier vorlegen ist ein dokument
des versagens die enorme summe von 50
milliarden geht nur noch zu 9/10 prozent
in beschaffung und innovation der rest
geht in den laufenden betrieb in
lohnanpassungen
versorgungsleistungen material erhalten
im betrieb von kasernen
betreiberverträge und in die platz
inflation letzteres schlägt auch im
bereich der verteidigung mit voller
wucht zu die 100 milliarden
sondervermögen sind die ende im nächsten
jahres nur noch 90 milliarden euro wert
in fünf jahren nur noch 62 milliarden
euro das ist das ergebnis ihrer
politik meine damen und herren
raul m
brecht hat gerade ausgeführt dass die
regierung viele sondern viele
rüstungsprojekte in den sonder etat
geschoben hat darauf wäre ich an ihrer
stelle aber nicht stolz denn damit lägen
sie zwei dinge offen erstes trotz der
herausnahme vieler investitionen über 23
milliarden aus dem regulären etat
steigen die gesamtausgaben das heißt
noch mehr geld für den laufenden betrieb
einer nicht einsatzbereiten armee und
zweitens die aus dem
sondervermögen die investition aus dem
sondervermögen sind die
kostensteigerungen der zukünftigen
betriebskosten denn jedes gerät was sie
jetzt über das sondervermögen geschaffen
steigert den ohnehin großen anteil für
den betrieb zusätzlich was die
bundesregierung hier vorliegt ist eine
tickende zeitbombe
für die bundeshaushalte der nächsten
jahre herr bundeskanzler
ihre zeitenwende ist keine zeitenwende
sie machen genauso weiter wie auch schon
als kabinettsmitglied unter merkel sie
haben die kraft nicht fähiges personal
einzusetzen und einen strukturellen
befreiungsschlag zu wagen stattdessen
blenden sie die öffentlichkeit mit
riesigen summen schulden geld für fair
aber die notwendigen investitionen in
den aufbau der bundeswehr deutschland
wäre nicht sicherer und auch nicht
unabhängige meine
[Musik]
meine damen und herren
dieser verteidigungshaushalt ist im
grunde ein
verwaltungshaushalt nur 19 prozent gehen
in kampfkraft und weiterentwicklung und
frau lambrechts sagte im ausschuss
beschafft wird was die soldaten brauchen
und nicht was die industrie verkaufen
will das gegenteil aber der stieg
geschieht sie bestellen unter anderem
weitere kurven k 130 die sogenannte k s
klasse die auf einen deal ihres
verblichenen spd genossen zurück aber
diese karten sind in der landes- und
bündnisverteidigung
völlig und brauchen wir und das ist nur
ein beispiel
das bmvg ist offenbar nicht viel sich
der neuen lage anzupassen sie kaufen
weiter für ihre gescheiterte
interventionspolitik ein obwohl sich die
sicherheitslage in europa seit 2014
drastisch verändert hat landes- und
bündnisverteidigung ist angesagt
schwenken sie um dieser
verteidigungshaushalt bis dafür nicht
geeignet er ist nur eines teuer als
partei der bundeswehr und der äußeren
sicherheit und müssen wir ihn ablegen
danke für aufregung
rüdiger lucassen war das hat ja unter
anderem
kritisiert dass es weniger geld für
militärische beschaffungen gibt
natürlich ist dort aber auch eine
erklärung dafür dass es eben das sonder
von bundeswehr gibt was für die
militärische beschaffungen 819
milliarden euro vorsieht liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen wer frieden und
freiheit erhalten will mehr
verbrecherische kriege wie in der
ukraine verhindern will der muss
verteidigungs fähig sein er muss im
zweifel auch bereit seien mit waffen
diese werte zu verteidigen
mehr das tun wir ja braucht soldatinnen
und soldaten er braucht menschen die
bereit sind diese werte im zweifel auch
mit ihrem leben zu verteidigen und
deshalb möchte ich ganz bewusst haben
beginn meiner rede unseren soldatinnen
und soldaten recht herzlich für ihren
einsatz danken
die kolleginnen kollegen die ampel aus
spd grünen und fdp hat um diese
verteidigungsfähigkeit der
bundesrepublik deutschland wieder
herzustellen die finanziellen
voraussetzungen in dem etat 2023 gelegt
mit dem sondervermögen 100 milliarden
euro und mit den mitteln im einzelplan
zusammenstehen in dieser
legislaturperiode inklusive des
laufenden etats in diesem jahr 300
milliarden euro für die bundeswehr für
die verteidigungsfähigkeit dieses landes
zur verfügung da sind schon im
kernhaushalt in der mittelfristigen
finanzplanung über neun milliarden euro
mehr
als die letzte cdu
verteidigungsministerin geplant hatte
und mit blick auf 2023 will ich noch mal
weiter heute ein paar falsche zahlen
kursiert sie noch mal richtig stellen
aus dem sondervermögen und aus dem etat
werden insgesamt
58,6 milliarden euro zur verfügung
stehen für die bundeswehr das in elf
milliarden euro mehr als in den
planungen der unions ministerin das sind
25 prozent das ist eh pokal im wandel
der finanziellen ausstattung und im
vergleich zu 2022 um das vielleicht auch
noch für den fraktionsvorsitzenden
richtig zu stellen gehen wir über 8,2
milliarden euro mehr ich finde das trübt
sehr deutlich aus wie diese zeitenwende
von der ampel in finanzieller hinsicht
beim bundeswehr etat gelebt wird
wenn wir diese mittel wollen wir
natürlich die nato quote erreichen
wollen wir diesem ziel näher kommen man
muss es auch historisch einordnen es ist
nicht nur absolut der höchste wert in
der geschichte der bundeswehr sondern
wir kommen auch im verhältnis zwischen
den mitteln für die bundeswehr und im
gesamt etat um ein großes schritt weiter
voran in die richtung die wir brauchen
werden bei der verteilung der mittel im
gesamthaushalt und deshalb ist es eine
historische wende die wir hier
beschreiben aber diese zeitenwende leben
ja nicht in der ampel nur finanziell
sondern die projekte sprechen auch dafür
frau ministerin dass wir die
vollausstattung
der soldatinnen und soldaten mit
persönlicher schutzausrüstung an den
beginn dieses sondervermögens dieser
fraktion gestellt haben zeigt dass wir
uns die soldatinnen und soldaten bei der
zeitenwende mittelpunkt stehen aber
auch die bewaffnung der krone oder die
nachfolge beschaffung für den tornado
und damit die fortsetzung der nuklearen
teilhabe sind inhaltliche beschreibung
dieses reh pokalen wandels und damit der
zeitenwende denn für uns in der ampel
wie in der ampel von spd grünen fdp wir
lassen uns leiten davon dass wir im
zweifel bereit sind unseren frieden und
freiheit mit waffen zu verteidigen und
über diese frage gab es ja liebe
kollegen von der union lange ein denke
ich keine lange schon ein konsens im
bürgerlichen lager aber uns ist es
gelungen in der ampel auf einen konsens
mit grünen und spd in dieser frage zu
erzielen und das ist wirklich ein team
eine tiefgreifende änderung der
politischen landschaft in deutschland
einen solch großen konsens haben wir
zeit in 60er jahren in dieser
gesellschaft nicht mehr erreicht und
auch dass gestreikt warum wir von einer
zeitenwende leben
aber die zeit am ende beschreibt auch
eine sache die wir in deutschland oft
nicht so genau sehen wollen das ist
nämlich die frage der führungsrolle wenn
es um die verteidigungsfähigkeit und die
verteidigung im nato-bündnis um in
europa geht unsere partner nation
erwarten schon lange eine führungsrolle
von von der bundesrepublik deutschland
und von der bundeswehr und wir füllen
diese führungsfunktion diese rolle jetzt
auch mit leben finanziell und inhalt
wenn wir zum beispiel auch als anlehnung
nation dienen wenn es um die neue
raketenabwehr für europa geht wir zeigen
dass wir diese führungsrolle ernst
nehmen liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
aber es sind natürlich nicht nur die
voraussetzungen finanzen und
inhaltlicher art sondern damit am ende
wie auch effektiv franken damit wir
diese verteidigungsfähigkeit
wiederherstellen können muss natürlich
das material und die ausrüstung auch bei
der truppe bei den soldatinnen und
soldaten ankommen und deshalb müssen wir
die prozesse sprechen wir haben dazu
schon erste schritte getan wir haben das
beschaffungs beschleunigungsgesetz auf
den weg gebracht die schwellenwerte
angepasst natürlich in einer
beibehaltung der kontrollrechte dieses
haus denn wir haben eine parlamentsarmee
aber wir müssen die prozesse noch weiter
verbessern in dem spannungsfeld dass wir
schnell sein wollen um die bundeswehr
möglichen auszustatten dass wir
natürlich berechtigt auch einen großen
anteil für die deutsche
rüstungsindustrie hier servieren und das
wird drittens aber möglichst viel von
den steuergeld in ausrüstung und
ausstattung investieren das heißt den
wettbewerb auch wirken können genau in
diesem spannungsfeld werden wir uns in
den nächsten wochen in den
haushaltsberatungen bewegen damit die
zeitenwende auch ihre wirkung entfalten
kann vielen dank für ihre aufmerksamkeit
karsten klein war das für die fdp hat
hier natürlich angesprochen es geht
nicht nur darum dass vorher geld fehlte
sondern auch das beschaffungswesen ist
noch zu kompliziert
dauert zu lange und auch daran
arbeitet die
verteidigungsministerin christine
lambrecht dass das schneller geht
vielen dank frau präsidentin meine sehr
geehrten damen und herren noch nie wurde
so viel geld in der bundesrepublik für
militärische ausrüstung ausgegeben und
noch nie war das leben so unsicher da
muss man doch über alternativen
nachdenken meine damen und herren wir
müssen das wettrüsten endlich stoppen
und einen dritten weltkrieg wenn dann
das ist die aufgabe
nach kriterien wie die regierung im
kommenden jahr 64 milliarden euro für
das militär ausgeben das ist also
wesentlich mehr als der einzelplan 14
und das ist mehr als die bildung
forschung familie senioren frauen jugend
wohnungsbau umwelt naturschutz nukleare
sicherheit verbraucht wird
wirtschaftliche zusammenarbeit inneres
und heimat insgesamt das ist auch eine
falsche schwerpunktsetzung meine damen
und herren wir sagen meine damen wir
müssen in den frieden investieren im
jahr 2010 hat die bundesregierung im
einzelplan 14
32 4 milliarden euro für das militär
ausgegeben
2022 waren es schon
50,4 das ist eine enorme steigerung und
gleichzeitig wird immer behauptet die
bundeswehr wäre kaputt gespart worden da
muss man doch mal die frage stellen wo
ist denn das viele geld geblieben warum
stellt außer uns niemand diese frage
meine damen und herren ich kann hier
nämlich die antwort geben werfen sie
doch einmal einen blick auf die
aktienkurse der rüstungsindustrie an dem
tag an dem der koalitionsvertrag der
ampel unterschrieben wurde stand der
aktienkurs zum beispiel vom
rüstungskonzern rheinmetall bei 82 euro
dann wurde das 100 milliarden
sondervermögen durchgepeitscht und die
aktie schoss auf einen wert von über 2
127 euro das ist eine verdreifachung des
kurses da knallten die korken bei den
besitzern dieser blutigen akt das muss
ihnen doch zu denken die mainland herrn
und frau lamprecht sie gehen jetzt mit 1
100 milliarden sondern das vermögen auf
einkaufstour sie wollen zum beispiel den
tarnkappenbomber
f-35 kaufen der verbraucht liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen von den grünen
in der stunde
5600 liter treibstoff wo ist denn
eigentlich der klimaschutz geblieben in
ihrem programm waren denken sich auch
über nicht mehr nach meine damen und
herren ich war mit mitgliedern des
haushaltsausschusses im juli in den usa
und wir haben mit politikern militärs
und backen herstellern gesprochen und
deren position war klar 100 milliarden
euro könnten aus deren sicht nur der
anfang sein sie wollen uns noch mehr
waffen verkaufen wir sagen als linke die
waffen nieder das ist eine linke
position bertha von suttner schrieben
schrieb 1900 punkt ihren roman die
waffen nieder sie einen
friedensnobelpreis und eine rechte
forderung war es nie die wache wieder es
wird über eine linke forderung bleiben
wir brauchen frieden
soweit gesine lötzsch von der
linksfraktion sie ist auch
haushaltspolitisch sprecherin ihrer
fraktion und der debatte lauscht
mittlerweile auf die wehrbeauftragte des
bundestags eva högl
liebe kolleginnen kollegen liebe
wehrbeauftragte meine damen und herren
thomas von aquin war nicht nur ein
religiöser aber auch ein weißer mann
dramatischer man es sagt einmal
verwundern muss man beten für
veränderungen aber arbeiten wie recht
hatte er doch denn meine damen und
herren der vorliegende verteidigungsetat
ist ganz sicher kein wunderwerk nein er
ist entstanden aus harter ehrlicher
mühsamer und letztendlich erfolgreicher
aber das getragen vom mut und der
entschlossenheit der veränderung
zusammen sind wir stark und diese zeit
erfordert mutige entscheidungen getragen
von geschlossenheit zu einem starken
staat gehört aber neben den
gesellschaftlichen zusammenhalt aber
auch und das merkt man den letzten
immer mehr die verteidigungsfähigkeit
und beides wird von dieser koalition
getragen und die veränderungen im
verteidigungshaushalt sind doch sichtbar
mit 50,1 milliarden verstetigt sich doch
das haut das haushalts niveau sehr hoch
und anders als in der finanzplanung
vorgesehen also noch in unserer großen
koalition 2023 26 steigen jetzt die
mittel verfüge um 12,4 milliarden
insgesamt an hinzu kommt noch die 100
milliarden aus dem sondervermögen das
ist gut so denn es handelt sich um
investitionen in die sicherheit und
freiheit vor allem auch künftiger
generationen das ist die dividende die
wir jetzt einbringen für unsere freiheit
und für die demokratie in unserem land
und in europa
wie bereits angesprochen gibt es neben
den kernhaushalt natürlich zusätzliche
mittel aus dem sondervermögen diese
betragen beispielsweise im jahr 2023
108,5 milliarden euro die wir hier
abrufen um wichtig und dringend
benötigen benötigte ausrüstung vorhaben
zu schaffen damit meine damen und herren
steigen die verteidigungsausgaben wie
bereits vom kollegen klein erwähnt auf
über 58 milliarden euro das ist
sicherlich viel geld aber der anblick
der derzeit im sicherheitspolitischen
lage in europa auch in der welt ist es
mit sicherheit gut investiertes geld
wir
investieren in die fähigkeit zu halt und
in die fähigkeitsentwicklung wir
investieren mit digitalisierung in wehr
technische forschung die teilweise auch
ins zivile leben einfluss hat und in die
erprobung von verschiedenen
waffensystemen aber auch material und
materialien ebenso
wird für die schutzausrüstung unserer
soldatinnen und soldaten weiter
investiert zweieinhalb milliarden euro
haben wir gleich zu beginn dieser
amtszeit auf den weg gebracht liebe
bürgerinnen und bürger eins ist klar die
beschaffung neuer waffensysteme
wird auch zu deutlich höheren
betriebsausgaben unter anderem für
material erhalten um personal und
natürlich auch zusätzliche gelder für
infrastruktur wir brauchen neue hangars
garagen aber auch kasernen für unsere
soldatinnen und soldaten und der kauf
der mv auf das war schon ein richtiges
zeichen das war eine mutige ein mutiger
schritt in die richtige richtung wir
werden mit diesen und den kommenden
verteidigungshaushalten die sicherheit
unserer einwohnerinnen und einwohner
garantieren können und vor allem wir
kommen unseren bündnisverpflichtungen
international nach insofern ist dieser
haushaltsentwurf auch ein zeichen dafür
dass dieses land dass diese gesellschaft
bereit ist verantwortung zu übernehmen
und dass wir dieser verantwortung auch
gerecht werden wollen man denke nur an
bereits getroffene entscheidungen und es
war ja fast schon ein star kato am
anfang ihrer registratur in sachen
entscheidungen ich denke thonabauer
folge schwere transporthubschrauber aber
ich denke auch an das thema
raketenabwehr wo wir jetzt gerade der
europäische motor für diese frage sind
aber meine damen und herren reden hier
nicht nur wir reden hier über viel geld
wir müssen natürlich auch und das ist
auch offen kommuniziert an den
schwachstellen im system arbeiten auch
hier wurden bereits von der ministerin
und im ministerium schon ganz schnell
wichtige aber auch mutige entscheidungen
getroffen am anfang ist natürlich
einiges mit der bundeswehr beschaffungs
beschleunigungsgesetz ein zungenbrecher
getan worden und mit diesem gesetz
sollen vergabeprozesse erleichtert und
beschleunigt werden ist auch dringend
notwendig und es kommt auch schon bei
der truppe an da kriegt man schon
rückmeldungen dass da einiges schon
funktioniert dabei sollte jedem klar
sein dass anschaffungen gerade
großprojekte nicht morgen realisiert
werden können das braucht einfach seine
zeit wir werden das sicherlich genau
beobachten wie viel zeit beansprucht und
sicherlich wird dieses parlament
beschaffungsprozesse auch kritisch
begleiten wir alle wollen und brauchen
eine leistungsfähige armee die zeitnah
und ohne bürokratische hindernisse die
ausrüstung erhält die sie braucht um
ihren aufgaben gerecht zu werden das
haben wir unseren soldatinnen und
soldaten unsere parlaments abi nicht nur
das haben sie nicht nur verdient nein
das ist dieses parlament den soldatinnen
und soldaten auch schuldig denn es gilt
nur zusammen sind wir stark und danke an
die soldatinnen und soldaten für ihren
einsatz
meine damen und herren eben dafür
benötigen wir diesen verteidigungsetat
und deswegen benötigen wir sicherlich
auch sehr viel geld im moment meine
damen und herren dies einzelplan ist
also ausdruck von notwendiger
veränderungen und harter arbeit und
dient der sicherheit und dem schutz
unserer demokratie er ist aber auch ein
zeichen ein signal an unsere
bündnispartner auf deutschland kann man
sich verlassen und anders als es hier
teilweise dargestellt wurde kommt diese
botschaft auch an man schätzt die
verlässlichkeit der bundesrepublik
deutschland sicherlich wird es bei
diesem haushaltsentwurf noch an der
einen oder anderen stelle veränderung
geben dafür sind wir als parlamentarier
auch da aber ich denke wir werden das
gemeinsam meistern und die zur verfügung
stehende mittel wirtschaftlich und
sinnvoll unser soldatin soldaten
einsetzen danke an das haus für die
transparenz und die unterstützung bei
diesem prozess auf die diskussion
verhandlung den nächsten wochen gespannt
und freue mich darauf dankeschön
andreas schwartz hat sich hier bedankt
bei der ministerin so natürlich auch wie
er mitglied der spd ist nächster redner
kommt von der opposition
reinhard anwalt cdu/csu-fraktion
präsidentin verehrte kolleginnen und
kollegen verehrte frau ministerin in
europa tobt ein krieg ende februar der
bundeskanzler von diesem pult aus die
zeitenwende ausgerufen im juni haben sie
mit unserer unterstützung ein
sondervermögen von 100 milliarden euro
zugebilligt bekommen seit der zeit
worden wir hier trat der tag auf eine
große konzeptionelle rede von ihnen frau
ministerin wie die bundeswehr der
zukunft aussehen soll wie sie das geld
ausgeben soll und wie sich deutschland
sicherheitspolitisch in dieser neuen
lage präsentiert und wir haben heute
auch wieder nichts von ihnen dazu gehört
die rede heute war ein tiefpunkt sie hat
drei teile der erste teil darin bestand
auf die große koalition zu schimpfen die
sie gerade hat sie selber angehört und
der zweite teil war die verdrehung der
geschichte stichwort tornados stichwort
drohnen meine kollegen von der spd
musste er selber lachen lässt sich die
geschichte hier gehören und der dritte
teil war dass sie nach klappern was
ihnen der bundeskanzler im rat zur
raketenabwehr vor gesagt hat meine damen
und herren das reicht nicht mehr geld
alleine reicht auch nicht wir haben eine
neue lage und wir brauchen dazu ein
neues konzept und es ist ja gut dass sie
in persönliche ausrüstung investieren
hat keiner was dagegen aber nur mit
neuen stiefeln und rucksäcken werden wir
unser land und unsere bündnispartner
nicht verteidigen können
und ich könnte jetzt viel sagen ich habe
beweise nur sechs minuten deswegen will
ich es auf sechs punkte mal beschränken
die ich ihnen für ihre nächste reden
mitgeben möchte erstens setzen sie
endlich die eckpunkte des
generalinspekteurs um zur steigerung der
einsatzbereitschaft zur reduzierung der
stabs lastigkeit zur stärkung der truppe
zur ausweitung der digitalisierung zur
erhöhung der effektivität das konzept
für die bundeswehr dazu kommt kriegt
doch auf dem tisch das einzige problem
für sie ist das ist die alte ministerin
unterschrieben hat deswegen ist es doch
nicht falsch stattdessen erfinden sie
jetzt im moment oder versuchen sie im
moment das gleiche noch mal neu zu
erfinden und verlieren tag für tag monat
100 in denen strukturell nichts passiert
setzen sie endlich um frau ministerin
zweitens informieren sie die
beschaffungsorganisation wir wollten es
in der letzten legislaturperiode seine
spd kollegen haben es verhindert jetzt
hat ein bundeskanzler der spd
angekündigt von nun an zwei prozent des
bips verteidigung zu investieren von nun
an
2022 mainz 1,5 prozent jetzt für 2023
plan sieht 1,6 prozent ich
prognostiziere ihnen sie werden es kaum
schatten dieses geld auszugeben und sie
werden 2024 auch die zwei prozent nicht
erreichen warum weil die
beschaffungsorganisation so wie sie
heute da steht bereits voll ausgelastet
ist es ist doch naiv zu glauben dass man
so ein system wenn man oben 100
milliarden euro enkheim kippt das die
menschen dadurch viel schneller und
besser arbeiten sie werden überlastet
und sie werden das nicht umsetzen können
und des presse brauchen wir reformen und
nicht irgendwann sondern jetzt
dreht ab und rufen sie einen großen
rüstungskäufe leyen
das institut der deutschen wirtschaft
hat im august eine studie veröffentlicht
in dem sie dargestellt haben dass die
mitarbeiter in der
verteidigungsindustrie seit 2015 die
mitarbeiterzahl zurückgegangen ist und
eine trendwende ist im moment nicht in
sicht haben sie sich schon mal die frage
gestellt wer das alles produzieren
sollen dass sie ab 2024 dem bestellen
oder wollen sie alle sind amerika kaufen
dafür müssen jetzt aber in deutschland
kapazitäten aufgebaut werden dafür
braucht die industrie jetzt
planungssicherheit und ich bitte sie
reden sie doch mal selbst mit den großen
geschäftsführern der unternehmen ich
habe sie noch auf keinem foto mit einem
sprechen sie fahren sie zu den
standorten reden sie auf den
betriebsversammlungen werden sie bei
jungen menschen in diesem bereich zu
entgehen wir brauchen die mitarbeiter
der verteidigungsindustrie sonst werden
wir die bundeswehr nicht ausrüsten
können ohne einen industrielle
zeitenwende wird ihre zeitenwende nicht
gelingen
legen sie strategien für die bedrohungen
der zukunft vor cyber welt künstliche
intelligenz drohnen und unsere
sicherheit wird in zukunft von vielen
faktoren neu bedroht werden das kann man
alles ganz furchtbar und schlimm finden
aber das wird einen angreifer nicht
davon abhalten diese technologien auch
gegen uns oder unsere verbündeten
einzusetzen und was ich mir von einer
verteidigungsministerin erwarte ist dass
sie nach vorne schafft dass sie eine
strategie entwickelt wie wir uns gegen
diese neuen bedrohungen wappnen können
davon habe ich heute bei ihnen kennwort
wird
fünfter fahren sie nach kiew sie haben
ja heute gesagt wie toll sie die ukraine
unterstützen fahren sie doch mal hin
sagt zeigen sie dem land dass sie es
ernst meinen mit der unterstützung sagen
sie dort was alles geht und nicht immer
nur was nicht geht nehmen sie eine
taskforce tauss beschaffungs experten
mit die dem land hilft in der in
deutschland waffen für die ukraine zu
kaufen anstelle neue ausflüchte für
verweigerte exportgenehmigungen zu
suchen das würde ihnen und uns und
unserem internationalen ansehen in der
welt ganz schön weiterhelfen aber ein
sechster und letzter tipp man hört sie
haben ein umfeld sehr viele soldaten
parteisoldaten ich rate ihnen sprechen
sie mal mehr mit den richtigen soldaten
die können ihnen sagen was die
bundeswehr wirklich braucht herzlichen
dank und alles gute
die sechs punkte von reinhard brandl
hier in der debatte
zum einzelplan 14 verteidigung auf ihn
folgt nun philipp krämer verbindet 90
die grünen
[Applaus]
frau präsidentin sehr geehrte
kolleginnen und kollegen der russische
angriffskrieg gegen die ukraine ist nach
wie vor das dominierende thema die
tapfere gegenoffensive der ukraine
beschäftigt uns gegenwärtig alle und
hierfür wünschen wir den ukrainischen
soldatinnen und soldaten viel erfolg
gerne auch mit weiteren militärischen
gütern aus deutschland
darüber hinaus brachten die letzten
wochen viele sicherheitspolitische
entwicklungen auf die ich im rahmen der
heutigen beratungen über den einzelplan
14 gerne eingehen möchte die beteiligung
der luftwaffe an der multinationalen
großübung pitch elektra two im
indopazifik zeigt einerseits die
hervorragende einbindung der
bundesrepublikanischen luftstreitkräfte
in alliierte und bündnis strukturen
andererseits aber auch die
herausforderung solcher komplexen
aufgabenstellungen mit der direkten luft
verlegung von sechs euro fightern
inklusive deutscher luftbetankung nach
australien haben die soldatinnen und
soldaten eine beeindruckende leistung
vollbracht das aber eine maschine auf
dem weg wegen hydraulischen
schwierigkeiten bei einem zwischenstopp
zunächst am boden bleiben musste zeigt
die technischen herausforderungen die
sich aus der größten luftwaffenbasen
seit gründung der teilstreitkraft und
der verwendung von modernen
waffensystemen ergeben wir danken der
luftwaffe ihren einsatz für die signale
des zusammenhalts diese den
partnerländern im pazifikraum dadurch
sendet und für ihren beitrag in dieser
übung auch solche alliierte
zusammenzuführen die traditionell
divergierende außenpolitischen
interessen und lesarten haben
komplexität ist auch das schlüsselwort
zu den aktuellen
sicherheitsherausforderungen hier in
europa wir begrüßen ausdrücklich den in
prag geäußerten ansatz des
bundeskanzlers eines gemeinsamen
europäischen integrierten luft
verteidigungskonzept die luftabwehr ist
seit der reduzierung der patriot
kapazitäten und dem aus phasen von
roland sowie des flugplatzes gelb hat
eine fähigkeit lücke deutsche
verteidigungs kapazitäten um diese zu
schließen braucht es energien
europäischen und weitere nato partnern
die im haushalt und im sondervermögen
veranschlagten investitionen im
luftverteidigungssysteme zeugen von
unserer bereitschaft gerade die oberen
schichten der gestaffelten
luftverteidigung zu schützen hierzu
sollte das system pad wird modernisiert
werden mit den aktuell soldatinnen und
soldaten der bundeswehr in der slowakei
stationiert sind um nach der abgabe der
slowakischen flugabwehrsysteme an die
ukraine die dortige luftverteidigung
aufrechterhalten zu können ihnen wie
auch den kameradinnen und kameraden die
gemeinsam mit unseren partnern air
policing an der ostflanke betreiben als
auch den teilen der
panzergrenadierbrigade 41 die nun dort
die neuen deutschen anteil an der efb
litauer und abbilden möchten wir
aufrichtig danken und den vier soldaten
glückwünschen
durch die in deutschland produzierten
flugabwehrsysteme die an die ukraine
geliefert werden kann nicht nur die
verteidigungsfähigkeit der ukraine
signifikant erhöht werden um zivile und
militärische infrastruktur vor
russischen angriffen zu schützen für die
luftwaffe können die gelieferten systeme
die luftverteidigung ebene unterhalb der
patriots systeme abdecken und eine
kosteneffiziente bekämpfung auch klein
wertiger ziele ermöglichen
weiter wird perspektivisch ein schutz
gegen ballistische mittelstreckenraketen
benötigt der auch unsere europäischen
nachbarn mit einschließen könnte ein
europäischer flickenteppich aus diversen
aber nicht integrierten fähigkeiten ist
allerdings dabei aus effizienz- und
kostengründen unbedingt zu vermeiden
gleichzeitig bleibt der schutz unserer
soldatinnen und soldaten im nahbereich
ein großes problemfeld gerade um die
bedrohung im einsatz durch neue und
kleine systeme wie mit sprengkörpern
bestückte handelsüblichen throne up zu
denken wie man sie im übrigen auch
gerade in der ukraine
oftmals müssen wir dringend eine lösung
finden bis diese gefunden ist gilt es
diese fähigkeit lücke durch
kooperationen mit alliierten
streitkräften durch international
zusammen im bündnis und der eu zu
schließen
ein weiteres sicherheitsrisiko das gerne
übersehen wird für unsere sicherheit
jedoch elementar ist liegt im weltraum
auch wenn hier wie generell in der
internationalen sicherheitspolitik
zusammenarbeite präferierte ansatz ist
zeigen russland und auch china durch
provokationen und offene agitation dass
sie aktuell keine vertrauensvolle
kooperation möglich ist da ist eine
lückenlose überwachung von potenziell
bedrohliche bewegungen von flugkörpern
eine wichtige kernkompetenz des weltraum
kommandos der bundeswehr die wir mit
diesem haushalt im rahmen der
zeitenwende auf den weg bringen wollen
meine damen und herren lassen sie uns
gemeinsam eine neue europäische
sicherheitsarchitektur entwickeln um
unsere demokratie und kollektive
sicherheit und freiheit zu schützen
herzlichen dank
und für die fdp fraktion hat das wort dr
michael
und michaela sitzt im haushaltsausschuss
wird die fraktion
[Applaus]
[Musik]
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin sehr
geehrte kollegen liebe zuschauer im saal
und bei youtube 58,6 milliarden euro für
verteidigungsausgaben sind in der tat
einen rekord-etat den das
bundesverteidigungsministerium im
nächsten jahr zur verfügung haben wird
das sind beträchtlich ausgaben die
hoffentlich dabei helfen werden die
verteidigungsfähigkeit unserer
streitkräfte zu verbessern wofür das
geld im einzelnen ausgegeben wird werden
wir in den kommenden wochen ja noch
ausführlich beraten da will ich auch
nicht vorgreifen weil wir haushalten
austausch mit dem ministerium sind
deswegen will ich heute gerne etwas zu
ein paar grundsätzlichen erwägungen
sagen die mich als haushälter
beschäftigen das beginnt damit dass für
mich vieles in der aktuellen
sicherheitspolitik der bundesregierung
logisch nicht so richtig zusammen geht
auf der einen seite haben die ampel
fraktionen und die union letzten sommer
in windeseile 100 milliarden euro
sondervermögen zur besseren ausstattung
der bundeswehr aufgelegt was
ausdrücklich auch damit begründet wurde
dass die armee nicht ausreichend
verteidigungs fähig sei man jetzt
schnell handeln müsse doch in diesem
jahr liegen die verteidigungsausgaben
aus diesem sondervermögen lediglich bei
1 90 millionen euro nächstes jahr sollen
sie dann immerhin auf 85 milliarden euro
ansteigen was tatsächlich eine große
steigerung ist aber eben keine so große
dass sie sich nicht auch regulär im
kernhaushalt abbilden lassen würden für
uns bestätigt sich damit genau das was
wir bereits vor der verabschiedung des
sondervermögens gesagt haben und zwar
dass wir diese sonder schulden gar nicht
brauchen und dass größere ausgaben im
verteidigungsbereich durch einsparungen
anderen etats finanzierbar ist
[Applaus]
aber dann hätte man ja tatsächlich
einmal sparen müssen und der wille dazu
war in der ampelkoalition ganz
offensichtlich nicht vorhanden vor dem
hintergrund der schlechten ausstattung
der bundeswehr ist es für uns auch nicht
nachvollziehbar wie die bundesregierung
ihre sanktionspolitik gegenüber russland
und die waffenlieferung an die ukraine
mit einer soliden sicherheitspolitik für
unser land zusammenbringen will was
meine ich damit wir haben in den
beratungen im letzten jahr immer wieder
darüber gesprochen dass die beschaffung
von rüstungsgütern nicht von heute auf
morgen geht im zuge der ukraine krise
ist die weltweite nachfrage nach
rüstungsgütern bestiegen die
auftragsbücher der rüstungsfirmen sind
voll und high tech ausrüstung hat auch
eine gewisse produktionsdauer ganz zu
schweigen davon dass da für rohstoffe
und teile benötigt werden die zum teil
durch die immer noch gestörten
weltweiten lieferketten nicht immer
sofort zu bekommen sind garniert wird
das ganze dann noch von einem ganz
normalen marktmechanismus heißt erhöhte
weltweite nachfrage bedeutet höhere
preise aktuell kommt jetzt noch die
wirkung der sanktionen dazu der
stahlhersteller arcelor mittal liegt in
bremen und hamburg die anlagen still
weil die in der die preise durch die
decke gehen und ich weiß nicht ob sie es
wussten aber auch stahl spielt bei der
produktion von rüstungsgütern durchaus
eine wichtige rolle
eine produktion sind natürlich nicht nur
stahl braucht sondern auch strom strom
den wir derzeit zu einem erheblichen
teil auch aus gaskraftwerken beziehen
sie ahnen vielleicht worauf ich hinaus
will kein gas kein strom kein strom
keine produktion von rüstungsgütern
keine rüstungsgüter keine verteidigung
die desolate ausrüstungs zustand der
deutschen streitkräfte derzeit ist hat
im juli die nzz auch noch einmal in
einem sehr gut recherchierten artikel
dargelegt und deutschland als
militärisches vakuum mitten in europa
bezeichnet und was ich mich nun frage
ist wie um alles in der welt eine
regierung vor genau diesem hintergrund
auf die idee kommen konnte genau das
land von dem man in puncto
energielieferungen abhängig ist mit
sanktionen zu überziehen und waffen an
seinen kriegsgegner zu liefern hat man
eigentlich nicht mal eine sekunde
darüber nachgedacht dass auf ein solches
verhalten eine entsprechende antwort
folgen könnte und wenn man die
sicherheitsinteressen dieses landes
ernst nimmt wie um alles in der welt
kann man dann noch auf die idee kommen
bei der derzeit mangelhaften
verteidigungsfähigkeit nun auch noch die
grundlagen einer adäquaten produktion
von ausrüstung zu gefährden ganz offen
die bundesregierung hat sich hier als
junge unerfahrene truppe präsentiert die
jetzt aus schaden klug werden muss ich
hoffe dass sie wenigstens intern ihre
fehler ehrlich analysieren und die
richtigen schlüsse ziehen alles andere
bedeutet eine gefahr für unsere
nationale sicherheit
[Applaus]
und für die fdp fraktion hat das wort
lassen
[Applaus]
frau präsidentin meine sehr geehrten
damen und herren liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen liebe frau dr hügel wir
debattieren heute den entwurf des
einzelplan 14
die betonung liegt auf entwurf es ist
ein regierungsentwurf und wie mein
kollege fricke ihnen auch schon ins
stammbuch geschrieben hat können sie ja
im rahmen der haushaltsberatungen
darüber noch anträge stellen wir sind
gespannt was sie uns da jeweils
vortragen werden wenn man auf diesen
entwurf aber schaut dann meine ich kann
man hier festhalten dass der schon
ambitioniert ist ambitioniert insofern
als dass man ihn natürlich vor dem
hintergrund sehen muss zu welcher zeit
er aufgestellt worden ist und was wir
damit vorhaben wir erreichen zusammen
mit dem sondervermögen was wir
dankenswerterweise haben hier im
deutschen bundestag implementieren
können mit hilfe der union ja wohl aber
wir haben es durch die große breite hier
im plenum getragen implementieren können
und wir werden mit diesem sondervermögen
das zwei prozent ziel im schnitt in den
nächsten jahren erreichen und es führt
uns dazu dass wir das unter einhaltung
der schuldenbremse
werden machen können das ist uns als fdp
ganz besonders wichtig und dann gibt es
dann gibt es kollegen die schauen dabei
dann haben die decke oder
frau lötzsch wie sieht das heute morgen
gemacht haben sie haben uns dann
vorgeworfen dass wir da so ein
besonderen fetisch vor uns hertragen ich
will ihnen gern sagen es wäre klug von
ihnen wenn sie bei dieser messung
besonderer bedeutung grad der verfassung
weil da steht das drin mit einstimmen
und ihre wählerinnen und wähler eben
auch wissen lassen dass es sehr klug ist
die verfassung an der stelle einzuhalten
wenn das nicht tun dann werden in der
zukunft und lassen sie mich noch mal
ausreden dann können sie auch dazwischen
rufen das ist sehr klug ist die
verfassung an der stelle einzuhalten
weil wenn wir es nicht tun werden wir in
der zukunft weder in der lage sein uns
zu verteidigen noch die dinge die sie zu
recht einfordern an sozialen dingen und
diesem land leisten können
als letzte erwägung die ich hier anfügen
möchte es ist heute an vielen stellen
kritisiert worden dass bundeskanzler
olaf scholz das wort zeitenwende benutzt
hat und dass dem nicht das befolgt sei
was der eine oder andere sich darunter
vorstellt ich will hier man
auch was er gesagt hat es ist das wort
zeiten wenn in den kreis der
internationalismus aufgenommen worden
mittlerweile wie glasnost und
perestroika dazu haben wir heute morgen
schon was gehört und wenn sie da lasse
ich sie gern daran teilhaben in die
länder der nato und an anderer stelle
weisen dann werden sie gefragt was
verstehen sie denn unter dem worte
zeitenwende und dann ist ja bis bedurfte
ausfüllung und wir verstehen darunter
dass diese neue rolle deutschlands in
europa und in der nato eine starke
bundeswehr braucht damit wird die
führungsrolle die andere von uns
erwarten dass wir sie übernehmen auch
ausfüllen können dafür sind die
notwendigen voraussetzungen gelegt
worden unter einhaltung der
schuldenbremse und ich darf ihn für
meine fraktion schon sagen dass wir
natürlich den aufwuchs im einzelplan 14
wenn er dann erfolgen muss wenn das
sondervermögen aufgebraucht sein wird in
diesem deutschen bundestag nicht nur
befürworten wenn wir werden alles dafür
tun dies auch durchzusetzen herzlichen
dank für ihre aufmerksamkeit
lars lindemann kündigte schon an wenn
die 100 milliarden euro sondervermögen
die natürlich für mehrere jahre jetzt
geplant sind aufgebraucht sind dann soll
der einzelplan 14 auch wieder steigen
ali al dailami jetzt für die
linksfraktion frau präsidentin meine
damen und herren ganze 64 milliarden
euro will die bundesregierung im
kommenden jahr für die verteidigung
ausgeben dass es ein neues rekordhoch
und somit der drittgrößte
haushaltsposten insgesamt damit trägt
deutschland innerhalb der eu auf platz
eins vor und werden einigen jahren durch
neue schulden in höhe von sage und
schreibe 100 milliarden euro nach den
usa und china die drittgrößte
rüstungsausgaben weltweit haben was für
ein wahnsinn möchte man da rein und
die verteidigung ministerin sie bieten
schnöde zu behaupten bei den
sonderschulen bundeswehr die es nicht um
aufrüstung sondern vor allem um die
ausrüstung doch unter dem titel
bekleidung und persönliche ausrüstung
für die soldatinnen und soldaten ist
noch nicht mal eine milliarde euro
vorgesehen die wahrheit ist dass fast 27
milliarden in die hochrüstung des
militärs versteckt werden noch mal 27
milliarden euro knapp vier milliarden
davon wollen sie alleine für den
störanfälligen f-35 atombombe
bereitstellen um in der lage zu sein in
deutschland gelagerten atombomben zu
transportieren und gegebenenfalls auch
abzuwerfen ist sage ihnen sparen sie
sich dieses geld stecken sie sind die
dringend benötigt die soziale
infrastruktur und den weder brauchen wir
atombomben auf deutschem boden noch den
dafür benötigten atombombe meine damen
und herren von der bundesregierung
während die bundesregierung also fleißig
aufrüstet streitet und falls sie seit
monaten um jeden euro wenn es um die
dringend benötigte entlastung der
menschen geht ihnen zu recht angst und
bange wird vor den kommenden monaten
aber auch jahren stattdessen erleben sie
und hören sie absurde wasch und spar
tipps von seiten gut situierter
politikerinnen und politiker und ein
christian lindner warnt gar vor einer
gratis mentalität diese streit machen
würde doch den rüstungskonzernen
milliarden in den rachen hinterher zu
werfen damit haben der habanera
finanzminister aber auch diese
bundesregierung überhaupt kein problem
während menschen nicht mehr wissen wie
sie über diesen winter kommen können wir
halten das für zu lesen um diesen
haushalt werden wir auch auf diesen
kunden nicht zustimmen danke für ihre
aufmerksamkeit
[Applaus]
[Musik]
der geehrte frau präsidentin verehrte
kolleginnen und kollegen sehr geehrte
damen und herren in der letzten woche
war ich gemeinsam mit der
staatssekretärin möller und einer
delegation in mali und niger der dortige
einsatz ist aktuell sicher der
gefährlichsten der bundeswehr die
gespräche dort vor ort mit den
soldatinnen und soldaten haben wir noch
einmal ganz deutlich vor augen geführt
welche verantwortung wir als abgeordnete
haben nicht nur wenn wir entscheiden ob
wir deutsche soldatinnen und soldaten in
auslandseinsätze schicken sondern auch
wie wir das tun bei der heutigen debatte
über den verteidigungsetat entscheiden
wir nämlich auch haben die soldatinnen
und soldaten die ausrüstung die sie
benötigen und ist die bundeswehr
personell und materiell für ihre
aufgaben ausreichend ausgerüstet die
mängel in der ausstattung der bundeswehr
sentieren hause hinlänglich bekannt
putins völkerrechtswidriger angriff auf
die ukraine hat sie uns allen noch mal
über deutlich vor augen geführt
dass andauern des krieges in europa
lässt uns jeden tag aufs neue in tiefer
betroffenheit und fassungslosigkeit
zurück aber auch wenn ihr fassungslos
sind so sind jedoch auf keinen fall loos
geblieben im gegenteil olaf scholz hat
im februar die zeitenwende hier im
parlament ausgerufen und die zeiten
haben sich in der tat geändert wir haben
schnell reagiert und ein sondervermögen
für die bundeswehr in höhe von 100
milliarden euro verabschiedet
das darf uns aber nicht genügen jetzt
ist die zeit noch mehr zu wagen zeit für
mutige entscheidung mut zur veränderung
mut um in der sicherheits- und
verteidigungspolitik neue wege zu gehen
olaf scholz hat gerade in prag über
unsere europäische zukunft gesprochen
und mutige ideen zur diskussion gestellt
zum beispiel die idee einer europäischen
luftverteidigung und die einer sehr viel
stärkeren verteidigungs zusammenarbeit
in europa das brächte nicht nur
effizient sondern wäre auch ein
erheblicher sicherheitsgewinn für uns in
europa dieser vorschlag ist mutig ja
aber eben weit mehr als nur ein
gedankenspiel es ist eine vision die
wirklichkeit werden kann wenn wir die
entsprechenden strukturen und
finanziellen voraussetzungen schaffen
und in den letzten monaten ist ja
bereits viel passiert die nato in der
deutschland eine zentrale rolle hat ist
auf dem weg zu einer wichtigen
erweiterung durch schweden und finnland
und gibt sich ein neues strategisches
konzept in deutschland eher arbeiten wir
gerade ressort übergreifend und im
dialog mit den bürgerinnen und bürgern
eine nationale sicherheitsstrategie hier
zeigt sich der vernetzte ansatz in ganz
praktischer ausprägung als mitglied im
verteidigungsausschuss und im ausschuss
für wirtschaftliche zusammenarbeit und
entwicklung weiß ich wie wichtig und
zielführend es ist dass wir da in der
außen- sicherheits- und
verteidigungspolitik sowie in der
entwicklungszusammenarbeit national und
international eng zusammenarbeiten
bezogen auf zentrale
haushaltsentscheidungen in bezug auf die
bundeswehr
werde ich immer wieder gefragt wo und
waren die mittel aus dem sondervermögen
denn nun eingesetzt werden warum seien
dann nicht mehr ausgaben getätigt wurden
wo doch die bundeswehr gegenmittel so
dringend braucht ich kann diese frage
gut nachvollziehen aber sehr geehrte
damen und herren richtig ist doch das
grundsätzliche änderung bei
militärischen beschaffungsvorhaben
of morgan passieren können in den
vergangenen jahren wurde zu oft und an
falscher stelle gespart es wurden
haushaltsmittel in effektiv eingesetzt
reformen im vergabeverfahren blieben aus
das führte zu einer dramatischen
material lage und zu einer langjährigen
unterfinanzierung der bundeswehr diese
lage können wir in der ampel nicht
innerhalb von wenigen monaten rückgängig
machen und adressiert gerade an unsere
soldatinnen und soldaten ich kann ihre
ungeduld sehr gut nachvollziehen und ihr
warten auf schnelle veränderungen und
verbesserungen ihrer ausstattung doch
ich bin sehr zuversichtlich dass wir
jetzt auf einem erfolgversprechenden weg
sind dass die ausrüstung der bundeswehr
nachhaltig verbessert wird
lassen sie uns in den kommenden wochen
darüber diskutieren die dir den
einzelplan 14 so gestalten dass wir die
trendwende ausbauen damit wir sicher
sein können dass wir unsere soldatinnen
und soldaten die bestmögliche ausrüstung
in für ihre einsetzung zur verfügung
stellen der regierungsentwurf ist
hierfür eine hervorragende grundlage und
ich freue mich auf gute verhandlungen
herzlichen dank
sagte becker scheinbar denn natürlich
wird jetzt dieser etat entwurf noch in
den entsprechenden ausschüssen
diskutiert und besonders der
haushaltsausschuss ist dort natürlich
gefragt aber auch der
verteidigungsausschuss und in diesen
sitz der nächste redner markus grübel
cdu csu fraktion
die präsidentin hat den
tagesordnungspunkt angekündigt mit
geschäftsbereich des bundesministeriums
der verteidigung um was geht's also es
geht um unsere sicherheit
es geht um frieden in europa unsere
demokratie unserem rechtsstaat unsere
freiheit auch unseren wohlstand all das
wird gesichert und geschützt durch das
geld aus dem einzelplan 14
wie auch beim auswärtigen amt
entwicklungsministerium innenministerium
alles was wir dieser tage diskutieren
ist sehr wichtig soziale absicherung
verkehrsinfrastruktur bildung
familienförderung all das ist sehr
wichtig aber ohne sicherheit und frieden
ist all das nicht viel wert wenn wir den
zu den menschen in der ukraine schauen
sehen wir dass menschen in
luftschutzbunkern menschen die trauern
menschen die sterben
zerstörte infrastruktur zerstörte
schulen krankenhäuser straßen fabriken
der krieg dauert schon über ein halbes
jahr und wir diskutieren den zweiten
haushalt in lichte dieses krieges und
darum verwundert dass der
verteidigungsetat stagniert ja sogar
schrumpft aus dem großen versprechen von
olaf scholz mehr als zwei prozent und
sondervermögen ist 2 prozent durch
sondervermögen geworden was dann
passiert wenn das sondervermögen
aufgebraucht ist oder wenn zusätzliche
investitionen zu tätigen sind über das
hinaus was im sondervermögen abgebildet
ist keine auskunft wir stehen vor einer
großen herausforderung einem tuch
herausforderungen und riesen hoch könnte
egal wer in zukunft regiert das wird
schwer zu stemmen sein glück bis 2026
jahr für jahr 32 milliarden auf
wachsenden übrigens die heutige am
letzten freitag gut herausgearbeitet
neben all dem klamauk war durchaus auch
substanz ich empfehle es zum nachschauen
bereits jetzt ist einzelplan 14 zu
gering wir sind konfrontiert mit
steigenden energiekosten personalkosten
beschaffungskosten 3 modelle plus 10,4
prozent eine situation die trifft nicht
nur die menschen in deutschland die
unternehmen sondern auch die
bundeswehrfahrzeuge flugzeuge schiffe
müssen betrieben und betankt werden und
die systeme die wir die sondervermögen
beschaffen auch die müssen betrieben
werden auch hierfür muss der haushalt
aufwachsen durch steigende aufwendungen
wird die möglichkeit für investitionen
im einzelplan 14 sinken in den nächsten
jahren auf die nulllinie kein geld mehr
für investitionen
des kein starkes zeichen für sicherheit
dass kein starkes zeichen gegen
aggressoren wie putin dass kein starkes
zeichen an unseren verbündeten und ist
auch kein starkes zeichen an unsere
sicherheitsindustrie wer will bei
solchen perspektiven investieren und
personal einstellen das ergebnis ist
dass die leistungsfähigkeit der
sicherheits und verteidigungsindustrie
nicht steigen wird dass die
waffensysteme nicht zeitnah zu laufen
wir brauchen aber jetzt schnell die
waffensysteme nicht in 10 oder 20 jahren
und auch unsere verbündeten brauchen
jetzt schnell modernen waffen stichwort
ringtausch wir brauchen auch moderne
waffen und munition zur unterstützung
des freiheitskampfes der ukraine es
braucht
verlässlichkeit und planungssicherheit
der krieg in der ukraine hat bei vielen
menschen in deutschland zum umdenken was
themen wie sicherheit und bundeswehr
angeht geführt das ist gut aber ich habe
den verdacht bei der koalition ist
dieses umdenken nicht nachhaltig eine
glaubwürdige zeitenwende ist ein
aufwachsen der verteidigungsetat eine
glaubwürdige seitenwände sorgt dafür
dass die herausforderungen bewältigen
bewältigt werden kann die ampel
koalition tut zu wenig der einzelplan 14
und die finanzplanung zeigen dies
deutlich
frau ministerin
lassen sie mich ein paar worte zu ihren
ausführungen machen
stimmt das oder habe ich recht dass die
finanzplanung durch den finanzminister
erstellt wird stimmt das oder habe ich
recht dass der letzte finanzminister
olaf scholz spd hieß
stimmt es oder habe ich recht dass die
nachfolge tornado durch die spd
blockiert würde stichwort rolf mützenich
stimmt das oder ob ich recht dass die
bewaffneten die drohne durch die spd
blockiert wurde fragen sie fritz
felgentreu dass deswegen zurückgetreten
frau ministerin frau ministerin sie
dürfen von der regierungsbank nicht
antworten tricks für sie es stimmt und
ich habe recht vielen dank
[Applaus]
grübel war das hat hier den ehemaligen
verteidigungspolitischen sprecher der
spd-fraktion fritz felgentreu
angesprochen
[Applaus]
ich weiß nicht wie es ihnen geht für
mich langweilt dass sie irgendwie klären
sie das doch untereinander sehr geehrte
präsidentin liebe kolleginnen meine
damen und herren liebe werbeauftraggeber
hügel
viele meiner kolleginnen und kollegen
aus der ampel haben schon wichtiges
gesagt darüber wie diese einzelplan
aufgestellten was wir geschafft haben
vor welchen herausforderungen wir auch
noch stehen für probleme haben wo wir
schon lösung gefunden haben deswegen
will ich ihre aufmerksamkeit jetzt auf
etwas anderes lenken in der letzten
woche waren mit einer delegation des
verteidigungsausschuss auf truppenbesuch
im sahel realistische gruppen bedrohen
dort zivilbevölkerung und staatlichen
sicherheitskräfte das engagement von -
mag kann in mali ein beitrag für mehr
sicherheit leisten die deutsche
ausbildung der nigrischen streitkräfte
hat eben diese in die lage versetzt
ebenfalls für mehr sicherheit zu sorgen
und da bleiben wir realistisch mehr
sicherheit nicht sicherheit
angesichts dessen was man vor ort
erreichen will kann das noch zu wenig
klingen für die männer frauen und kinder
in mali und niger die davon profitieren
ist es viel wert auf dem human
development index der vereinten nationen
belegt legend niger den letzten platz
durch dürren überschwemmungen konflikte
und vertreibung wird liga derzeit von
der schlimmsten krise der
ernährungssicherheit in diesem jahrzehnt
heimgesucht über vier millionen menschen
18 prozent der bevölkerung sind auf
sofortige humanitäre hilfe angewiesen im
seil ist gerade regenzeit stempels
vergleichsweise grün trotzdem ist es zu
wenig um das viel gut zu versorgen auf
unserer reise sagen wir ausgemergelte
tiere ab und zu auch tierkadaver in der
herde die überflutung in dieser
regenzeit sorgt allein in niger für
mindestens 75 tote und über 100.000
geschädigte den bäuerinnen gehen mit
ihren feldern jedes jahr wieder zu nah
an den fluss der eine gute erde
verspricht doch lebensbedrohlich sein
kann an größere teile des landes werfen
oft nicht genug ab um die bäuerinnen und
ihre familien zu versorgen
oder ein motorrad und ein
maschinengewehr viel mehr braucht es
nicht damit sich immer wieder junge
menschen brutalen gruppen anschließen um
sich selbst zu versorgen und dabei die
bevölkerung tyrannisieren flucht und
vertreibung produzieren ganzen schrecken
verbreiten hunger ein motorrad und ein
maschinengewehr das engagement der
bundeswehr in sachen steht im haushalt
23 nicht in frage mit der marie noch nie
gut so aber die posten die in den
anderen häusern
armut bekämpfen helfen können armut zu
bekämpfen die sollen laut
regierungsentwurf schrumpfen der beitrag
zum welternährungsprogramm der vereinten
nationen sondern auf 28 millionen euro
gekürzt werden die ausgaben für die
sonne initiative eine welt ohne hunger
25 prozent weniger ehrlich gesagt frage
ich mich warum der vernetzte ansatz der
bundesregierung die koordination
militärischer und ziviler mittel zum
erreichen gemeinsamer ziele ist ohne
entsprechende haushalterische
unterfütterung der zivilen mittel nicht
wirklich gut umzusetzen und so lange die
lage im saal so ist dass deutsche
soldatinnen auf patrouille von kindern
aus der ferne um essen angebettelt
werden solange werden realistische und
andere kriminelle gruppen immer wieder
jugendliche und erwachsene finden die
sich ihnen anschließen
manche tun so als bräuchte es kein
militär um die lage dort zu verbessern
wir wissen dass das nicht stimmt
motorrad und maschinengewehre auch ohne
hohen tödliche werkzeuge und
dschihadismus lässt sich nicht mit
nahrungsmitteln allein ein denn ich bin
den soldatinnen im saal für ihr
engagement auch in politisch
herausfordernden zeiten sehr dankbar was
sie dort unter schwierigen bedingungen
leistung kann man sich hier kaum
vorstellen doch auch über die tiere
hilfe der kampf gegen armut und
entwicklungspolitik sind in der
sicherheitspolitik unerlässlich der
haushalt der bundesrepublik deutschland
muss dem vollständig rechnung tragen und
hier müssen wir noch mal ran
ich möchte auf zwei bemerkungen machen
zu der debatte gerade weil mich das
einfach wirklich stört das erste ist
frau ministerin ich gehe mal davon aus
dass sie mit locker flockig nicht den
vorschlag den ich mit zwei ampel
kollegin gemacht habe zu der frage wie
können wir die ukraine weiter
unterstützen niemand nimmt das locker
und wir wissen alle dass es keine
flockige situation ist
[Applaus]
und eine anmerkung kann ich mir nicht
als fans mit den kollegen der
linkspartei auch nicht gefahr laufen
dass sich da noch mal zu euch hin
was genau schlage sie den vor solche
russland das baltikum angreifen
kapitulation
ist es das was schlagen sie dann vor
wenn die polnischen nachbarn angegriffen
werden kapitulation
auch für deutschland ich glaube dass die
links verteilt sich dieser frage stellen
muss es macht mir schmerzen ihn dabei
zuzugucken wie sie das einfach nicht
wahr ist
sawani war dass die sprecherin für
sicherheit frieden und abrüstung hat
hier schon mal auf den nächsten
einzelplan hingewiesen entwicklung denn
unter anderem steht dort dass die
beiträge an die vereinten nationen un
unter anderem
nichtregierungsorganisation halbiert
werden sollen im vergleich zu diesem
jahr die präsidentin liebe kolleginnen
und kollegen hätten sie nach aufwachen
bei einer rakete von ihrer unterkunft
einschlägt weil die alarmsirenen ihren
ohren dröhnt und die fenster wackeln von
der druckwelle dann wissen sie dass ihr
land zu wenig für verteidigung
ausgegeben hat college und wenn sie mit
ihrer familie
in einem park gehen und in diesem park 1
rakete einschlägt und davon ob länder
wie dieses weggesprengt werden in brake
für die letzte woche erst wieder
passiert dann wissen sie dass
verteidigung wichtig ist und dann wissen
sie auch dass zeitenwende wichtig ist
ich habe letzte woche ich habe letzte
woche
auf meiner reise in die ukraine in kiew
viele gespräche geführt ich habe in den
haag mit leuten gesprochen ich habe vor
dem staatsanwalt von agef diese kleinen
metall würfel hier mitgegeben bekommen
die bei die in diesem parks einschlagen
die hunderttausenden alles zu schätzen
dass in einem bestimmten radius ist und
ich glaube das macht sehr deutlich dass
dieser verteidigungshaushalt von dem wir
heute sprechen kein normaler haushalt
ist das ist kein normaler haushalt bei
bear creek haben mitten in europa und
deswegen
investiert diese koalition drei
milliarden mehr in diesen
verteidigungshaushalt als die
vorgängerregierung ist vorgesehen hat
deswegen haben wir ein sondervermögen ja
mit sehr großer mehr ein sondervermögen
auf den weg gebracht das es uns
ermöglicht zu investieren deswegen
werden wir dauerhaft zwei prozent
unseres bruttosozialprodukts in die
können verteidigungen investieren das
ist alles wichtig und damit werden wir
die bundeswehr modernisieren wir werden
altes gerät durch ein neues ersetzen und
das ist gut für uns und das ist gut für
unsere bündnispartner und das ist die
erste priorität meine damen und herren
und es gibt eine zweite priorität und
das ist die militärische unterstützung
der ukraine und auch das ist ein teil
der zeitenwende wir werden altes gerät
durch neues ersetzen wir werden zum
beispiel ein schützenpanzer marder der
wird in den kommenden jahren die
bundeswehr verlassen der transportpanzer
fuchs wird durch ein neues gerät ersetzt
er befähigt uns dazu die ukraine genau
damit zu unterstützen anteilig auch
jetzt schon und auch das ist ein
wichtiger teil dieser zeitenwende ja
zwei teile beide sind wichtig beide sind
notwendig und dieser haushalt befähigt
uns dazu beide teile umzusetzen welt
irgendwie nicht dem finanzminister
christian lindner dankbar dass er einen
haushaltsentwurf vorgelegt hat ja diese
zeitenwende ermöglicht das bin ich auch
dankbar dass diese koalition diesen
haushaltsentwurf mit trägt der diese
zeitenwende vollumfänglich umsetzen kann
denn es liegt auch in unserer hand es
liegt in unseren händen zu ermöglichen
dass man im durch ein mit seiner familie
friedlich durch einen park gehen kann es
liegt in unserer hand zu ermöglichen
dass man friedlich schlafen kann in
berlin und köln aber auch in haag
amateurs oder butscher vielen dank
marcos vater war das bis vor kurzem noch
verteidigungspolitischer sprecher aber
auch immer noch mitglied im
verteidigungsausschuss
auf ihn folgt ingo gädechens cdu csu
fraktion und beruf sollte
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen frau
wehrbeauftragte meine sehr verehrten
damen und herren ich bin meinem
liberalen kollegen als vorredner dr
markus farbe sehr dankbar selbsterlebtes
in der ukraine hier dargestellt zu haben
denn in der täglichen diskussion sage
ich mal verblasst ein wenig das was in
der mitte europas zur zeit passiert
nämlich dass wir einen brutalen angriffs
krieg russlands haben und meine
hochachtung gilt einen tapferen
ukrainerinnen und ukrainer die sich
diesen brutalen angriffskrieg
entgegenstellen
und wenn wir jetzt dass eine 90-minütige
debatte hinter uns haben über den
einzelplan 14 über verteidigungspolitik
kann ich natürlich sehr gut verstehen
dass die ampel koalitionäre den etat als
ausreichend als aufwachsen dargestellt
haben dass die
bundesverteidigungsministerium hier eine
blumige rede hält die man wenn man sie
aber dann analysiert schon in den ersten
teilen im zahlenwerk zerfällt und das
meine damen und herren werden wir als
cdu csu fraktion nicht durchgehen lassen
fangen wir aber trotzdem noch mal mit
etwas positivem zu den 15 milliarden
milliarden im originären einzelplan 14
sollen 2023 knapp 8,5 milliarden euro
aus dem sondervermögen gekommen dass das
100 milliarden sondervermögen nun
endlich umgesetzt wird es zunächst mal
eine gute nachricht das hätten wir aber
auch schon im laufenden haushalt in
größerer summe haben können aber das
funktioniert nur ohne zaudern zögern und
ohne falsche prioritätensetzung seis
drum fast ein skandal ist aber dass der
ampel haushalt trotz gegenteiliger
versprechungen dauerhaft bei 50
milliarden gedeckelt eingeworben
eingefroren werden soll das führt
geradewegs in eine finanzielle
schieflage der gesamten bundeswehr und
das wissen sie frau ministerin und
protestieren trotzdem nicht lautstark
genug dagegen was bedeutet das konkret
schon in diesem haushalt sinkt der
investitionsanteil um 3,5 prozentpunkte
diese entwicklung wird sich bei einem
gedeckelten
verteidigungshaushalten automatisch
fortsetzen verbunden mit steigenden
personal betriebs und
instandhaltungskosten
lampen wir also in kurzer zeit bei einer
investitionssumme von null euro und
haben damit null spielraum für neue
waffensysteme diese absurde
finanzplanung kann man auch als
fehlgeleitete zeitenwende bezeichnen bei
einem gedeckelten getan reicht das geld
einfach nicht aus noch schlimmer finde
ich die tendenz aber
die das bundesverteidigungsministerium
einschlägt die unterfinanzierung und
auch die aktuelle einsatzbereitschaft
der bundeswehr mit allen kräften zu
verschleiern bis heute sechs monate nach
der von bundeskanzler angekündigten zeit
und wände hat diese bundesregierung
keinen plan vorgelegt in welchem
zeitraum das sondervermögen ausgegeben
werden soll
offensichtlich versucht man sich hier
irgendwie durch zuvor standen das ist
aber keine seriöse planung für die
truppe und erst recht nicht keine
angemessene informationspolitik
gegenüber diesem parlament die
bundeswehr ist und bleibt eine
parlamentsarmee
gerade in dieser schwierigen zeit mit
steigenden inflationsraten
und explodierenden preisen bei material
und munition müssen wir als abgeordnete
vollumfänglich und rechtzeitig
informiert werden
müssen auch informiert werden wie es um
die einsatzbereitschaft der bundeswehr
steht aber da kommen nur plattitüden aus
dem ministerium
der bericht zum materiellen
einsatzbereitschaft der uns
parlamentarier über genau diesen zustand
informieren soll wird mitten im keine
krieg komplett
umgestaltet wenn wir als abgeordnete
dadurch mehr und umfassendere
informationen erhalten solle wäre das
grundsätzlich eine gute entwicklung
unserer antwort liches allerdings den
bisherigen berichten einzustellen um so
den parlamentariern zentrale
informationen vorzuenthalten
deshalb wäre es gewesen das alte
berichts format beizubehalten um dann im
laufenden betrieb auf ein neues format
umzuschwenken
ein schelm der absicht oder sogar böses
dabei denkt ein weiteres beispiel ist
das fähigkeitsprofil oder bzw
fähigkeitsprofil und die fähigkeit lage
das sind zwei wichtige dokumente die
verteidigungspolitiker wissen dass die
den aktuellen soll- und ist-zustand der
bundeswehr wiedergeben und das muss man
sich mal auf die zunge auf der zunge
zergehen lassen laut
verteidigungsministerium die grundlage
des finanzbedarfs für die bundeswehr
sind und genau diese dokumente will ihr
ministerium frau ministerin nicht
herausrücken und verweist darauf um es
auf die spitze zu treiben dass wir
abgeordneten zu unqualifiziert seien die
dokumente zu verstehen dass liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen geht einfach
gar nicht um das ausdrucken eine aktoren
auffassung zwischen
regierung und parlament
zum abschluss möchte ich noch einmal auf
die ukraine zu sprechen kommen seit
ihrem amtsantritt frau ministerin haben
sie im leitungsbereich zwei höchst
dotierte b sechster am post neu
geschaffen alle einmal für den leiter
des staates der staats und
informationsarbeit und zusätzlich für
ihren persönlichen beauftragten
politische beratung für grund
angelegenheiten und kommunikation was
immer die herren oder damen auch zu tun
haben und eigentlich sollte damit wohl
die kommunikation aus ihrem hause besser
werden auch jetzt läuft gerade wieder
etwas über ticker die
informationspolitik aus dem bmvg das
eigentlich konfuser geworden seit
februar stelle ich mit erstaunen fest
dass sie bei der frage nach
waffenlieferungen an die ukraine fast im
wochentakt von einer grenze reden
nämlich von einer grenze dessen was wir
aus der bundeswehr noch abgeben können
habe ich anfangs noch vermutet dass
substanz hinter dieser antwort steht bin
ich mehr und mehr enttäuscht und nicht
nur wir parlamentarier begleiten das ja
kritisch in unseren anfragen dem
fachausschuss auch im haushaltsausschuss
sondern mehr und mehr kritisieren dass
auch die medien tun sie alles denn die
freiheit die demokratie und unsere werte
werden auch in der ukraine verteidigt
und zwar von daher müssen wir alle
anstrengungen unternehmen die ukrainerin
ukrainer bei ihren tapferen kampf zu
unterstützen und dazu gehört auch
material aus der bundeswehr herzlichen
da nicht sehr viel
[Applaus]
diese plant rossmann spd
präsidentin frau wehrbeauftragte frau
bundesministerin manche kolleginnen und
kollegen halten das für undankbar die
letzte rede in einer so großen debatte
zu halten hier gibt es natürlich die
möglichkeit noch mal mit den irrtümern
der opposition aufräumen zu können an
dieser stelle meine sehr verehrten damen
und herren meine selbst werden damen und
herren gerade in der jetzigen zeit in
der krieg nach europa zurückgekehrt ist
sollte es allerdings tatsächlich nicht
liebe union nur um haushalterische
spitzfindigkeiten gehen herr gerdes ihr
redebeitrag geben hat er den eindruck
vermittelt dass sie tatsächlich an und
vom thema bundeswehr haben insofern
lades jedoch herzlich einmal den
verteidigungsausschuss zu kommen sie
würden die fraktionen wirklich bereich
und dort
meine sehr verehrten damen und herren
aus meiner sicht aus meiner persönlichen
sicht das ist schlicht egal es ist
schlicht egal wie viel prozent von was
jetzt ausgegeben wird es geht
ausschließlich darum die eingesetzten
steuergelder klug auszugeben um gut
ausgerüstet und personell gut
ausgestattete streitkräfte und eine
leistungsfähige und effektive
bundeswehrverwaltung zu haben und klug
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen von der
union
halt gerade nicht geld um jeden preis zu
veranschlagen das dann wie in den
letzten jahren immer wieder geschehen
gar nicht ausgegeben werden kann war das
beschaffungs system sie haben selber
häufiger event an seine
kapazitätsgrenzen gelangt es bzw voller
und seele wahnsinniger regelungen ist
die unsere bundesministerin jetzt angeht
insofern möchte ich den entwurf der
bundesregierung an dieser stelle
ausdrücklich begrüßen ausgaben herr
kollege die unmittelbar getätigt werden
müssen um die gravierendes
notwendigkeiten sicher zu stellen wären
auch unmittelbar getätigt ausgaben die
von preisverhandlungen mit der industrie
technischen entwicklungen harmonisierung
in der interoperabilität mit partnern
abhängen werden dann getätigt wenn sie
entscheidungsreif sind und nicht vorher
nach vielen jahren der ungenügenden
ausstattung und fehlenden investitionen
in personal material infrastruktur und
unterhaltung von ihnen scharf kritisiert
stellt der entwurf der bundesregierung
frau ministerin exakt die richtigen
weichen
zur verdeutlichung zur verdeutlichung
einige fakten die verteidigungsausgaben
im einzelplan 14 für 20 23 liegen ganz
unabhängig von mit dem 100 milliarden
programm das mehrfach gesagt worden um
rund 2,8 millionen euro über der
finanzplanung wie sie für das jahr 20 20
stimmt oder habe ich recht unter
verteidigungsminister an kramp
karrenbauer vorgesehen waren denn der
verteidigungshaushalt meine damen und
herren den manchen titeln reduzierungen
beinhaltet dann doch nur diebe union
weil es unsinnig wäre weiter hunderte
millionen in einen für einen einsatz in
afghanistan vorzuhalten das stand im
entwurf der schlichte endet ist es ist
auch gut und richtig meine damen und
herren die kosten für den einsatz
deutschlands soldatinnen und soldaten in
nordafrika zu reduzieren wenn wir doch
richtigerweise an mancher stelle das
sind entscheidungen dieses hauses unser
engagement reduziert haben oder auch sie
haben sie eben erwähnt die 2 3
milliarden euro investitionen die stadt
im einzelplan 14 nun im sondervermögen
abgebildet werden und deshalb
logischerweise im einzelplan 14
wegfallen liebe union dieser
verteidigungshaushalt den einzelplan 14
ist ein beispiel für haushaltswahrheit
und haushaltsklarheit
mehrausgaben hingegen mehr ausgaben
hingegen sind dort vorgesehen wo sie
dringend benötigt sind
487 millionen zu planen stellungen
verbesserung das kann man kritisieren
aber da geht es um die besoldung das
erhalt unserer soldatinnen und soldaten
dafür schämen wir uns nicht es geht um
320 millionen euro erhöhungen sind
material instandhaltung es geht um 299
millionen euro erhöhung für die
ausstattung der bundesländer damit
endlich die ruhe in den ruinösen kann in
der kaserne bauten saniert werden können
da müssen wir endlich liefern und das
tun wir es geht um 274 millionen euro
erhöhung bei den versorgungsleistungen
wir vergessen die ausgeschiedenen
soldatinnen und soldaten nicht und
kümmern uns auch um die
363 millionen euro erhöhung unter
anderem für einen besseren beleg dass
des bekleidungs wesens und meine damen
und herren erlauben sie mir noch eine
einordnung verteidigungsausgaben nach
dem sogenannten nato kriterien wenn wir
zum beispiel das amt der beauftragten
die verteidigungs lassen und zu sagen
mit dem ausländischer streitkräfte et
cetera et cetera dann gehen wir gar
nicht 50,1 millionen euro aus sondern es
wurde eben leider von falscher stelle
gesagt insgesamt sind es 64 millionen
und milliarden euro 64 milliarden euro
für unsere sicherheit quatschen sich
dazwischen wenn der kuchen redet meine
damen und herren
64.000 milliarden 1000 millionen euro
für das jahr 20 23 sind eine verdammt
große menge geld und ich bin der
bundesregierung dankbar dass es dieses
viele geld verantwortungsvoll und klug
ausgibt und freue mich auf die weiteren
beratungen vielen dank
[Applaus]